Guten Morgen Tim Tim ich hoffe du stirbst.
Du deine Mutter schwitzt beim.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 263 und heute geht richtig zur Sache ne.
Am Freitag den 27 Juli 2018.
Genau er will eigentlich beide im Urlaubsmodus also ich auf jeden Fall sehr.
Mein ganzes Leben ist ein einziger Urlaub.
Das stimmt das stimmt.
Aber wie das so ist wenn man hat Angst vor Montag das bedeutet man hat Angst davor dass der Urlaub irgendwann vorbei ist.
Ja also ich fand es immer schlimm wenn du wenn so Sommerferien sechs Wochen Sommerferien und dann auf einmal so am Montag übrigens Schule Linus ne also.
Na gut die Zeiten sind ja jetzt.
Lass mich hier ersetzt nicht zurück.
Wetter für war noch gerade ganz gut ich blicke hier auf ein spektakuläres Bergpanorama während der Aufnahme und gib WLAN also ich bin glücklich und daher alles super ja und so.
Das heißt es gibt WLAN das heißt du bist nicht in Deutschland.
Richtig.
Ach jetzt habe ich noch gar nicht hier in die in der das in der Feedback.
Das echt Feedback genauer da war so einiges einiges gekommen.
So ein einige Stellen es wurde an mehrere Stellen in Deutschland welche bestellt.
Tapeshe sind schon fast aus bei Amazon.
Dann Gassi.
Ja es wurde vor allem viel spekuliert über die Aussprache,
oder gibt's natürlich auch verschiedene Fraktionen da gibt's dann z.b. die Fraktion die sagt na ja in meinem Lateinunterricht war das immer so,
gibt allerdings habe ich gerade nicht parat hat nur diesen schönes Video gefunden wo jemand mal so in diese
ganze Sprachforschung und Lautbildung reingegangen ist wo sie anhand von diversen Kriterien mal nachgeforscht haben wie denn wohl die Aussprache tatsächlich gewesen sei damals so dass jetzt nicht mehr ganz zusammen was du die Kriterien waren war auf jeden Fall das interessant sein
geht das für die schon aus noch mal rausgesucht.
Aber so allgemein anerkannt und unbezahlte das ist irgendwie nicht und von daher machen wir das jetzt einfach so wie es wie wir es für richtig halten.
Altes data ist das jetzt bei uns habt ihr es zuerst.
Dimitri kommentiert noch zum Rundfunkbeitrag Grund von Beitrag war natürlich auch so einen Kommentar
Thema mein Kritikpunkt an Rundfunkbeitrag ist das der größte Teil des Geldes eben nicht ins Programm geht,
oder in die Technik sondern in die Gehälter der Intendanten und die Pensionsansprüche aller Mitarbeitern
ebenso das ARD und ZDF das Geld nur so aus dem Fenster rauswerfen nach dem Motto jeder Behörde wenn wir in diesem Jahr sparen haben im nächsten Jahr weniger Kapital richtig ja stimmt und da hat das noch natürlichen. Angesagt bei jeder Behörde so so wird gerne von jedem Sender ein Reporter rausgeschickt der Vorort mit nahezu den gleichen Bildern berichtet
auch das muss nicht sein nicht zuletzt wurde auch den öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien eine tendenziöse Berichterstattung nachgewiesen da fehlt jetzt der Link
von wem ist nachgewiesen wurde dafür aber jetzt Amazon in der letzten Sendung klar gesagt dass trennen wir jetzt erstmal von der vom Rundfunkbeitrag selber ne also Kritikpunkt am Rundfunkbeitrag kann ja jetzt nicht mehr die
die der Inhalt der Berichterstattung sein auch wenn es da sicherlich auch immer wieder mal was zur zu kritisieren gibt ich muss auch dazu sagen wenn ich irgendwie öffentlich-rechtliche sage dann.
Denke ich eigentlich an die Produktionen von ard-aktuell namentlich Tagesschau
und Tagesthemen weil was anderes gucke ich nicht insofern ist da auch mein Blick natürlich sehr stark
limitiert den ich das kann man hier auf jeden Fall an mehr.
Ja selbst wenn man mit der ganzen,
also wenn man mit der mit den Produktion im Einzelnen nicht einverstanden ist was er auch vollkommen okay ist und was auch vollkommen nachvollziehbar ist und
was auch eine Kritik ist die geäußert werden muss damit es sich eben nicht,
weiter verschlechtert weil muss ja auch mal sehen in welchem Rahmen hält sich dann das so im internationalen Vergleich so ich geh,
ganze Menge Länder die wären ganz froh auf dem Level zu sein wo wir sind.
Und es ist halt so oder so ist es eben auch ein mäßigen da und Standards setzen da Faktor
für alle anderen die eben nicht in in diesem Modus sind und wie weit das auseinanderklaffen kann.
Gutes ist schon fast so ein bisschen die Keule in der Argumentation jetzt mit den USA anzukommen aber USA halten ganz schlechten öffentlich-rechtlichen Bereich also eigentlich keinen sonst läuft er irgendwie auch eher so über Spenden mit nPA die machen zwar ganz gute Sachen aber die haben halt einfach nicht diese definitionshoheit
der der Networks und schon gar nicht von dieser von den localtv Networks wo er halt auch gerade die nächste Übernahme Welle Brot und da gerade eine Schlacht vor dem SCC ausg,
horten wird ob irgendwie diese Bude Sinclair da alles übernehmen kann und quasi die
diese staatliche fox news Gleichschaltung auch noch bei den ganzen lokalen TV-Sender platziert davon sind wir noch weit entfernt und davon müssen wir eben auch so weit entfernt bleiben wie es mir irgendwie geht
so da ist er auf jeden Fall schonmal so eine solide finanziert System ganz gut dass da kann man sie jetzt lange drüber unterhalten wie groß jetzt irgendwie eine Pension ist oder nicht
ja what's the point also ich meine Leute die sein Leben lang arbeiten die verdienen dann halt irgendwie in dann haben Sie die auch Pensionsansprüche so ist das halt so ist es ja auch in anderen Berufen auch
warum sollte das da jetzt nicht so sein.
Das ist einfach das Thema will ich jetzt gar nicht unbedingt so in der Größe aufmachen aber die die
Entlohnung von irgendwie Leuten im Dienste des Staates ist natürlich immer.
Ein ein Thema da wenn man irgendwie
sich z.b. auch anschaut was Abgeordnete für Diäten kassieren dann wird halt irgendwie schnell mal gesagt fast unglaublich sind so viele 1000 € für für Noppes ne andererseits ist die Argumentation diese Idee Diäten möglichst hoch zu halten dass sie eben nicht,
damit diese Leute eben auch genug Geld haben und nicht in wie viel Kaution anfällig werden ganz ganz ganz anderes Thema so wollte ich nur mal noch kurz angemerkt haben das
das natürlich auch auf wechseln wechseln in der Gesellschaft diskutiert wird nämlich hier in der Regel
danach bemessen was in der freien Wirtschaft zu holen ist und was nicht ja also Leute in in öffentlich-rechtlichen oder in
in in Beamten Positionen werden in der Regel so immer zweierlei ein Jahrzehnt lang ausgelacht weil sie für so wenig Geld arbeiten müssen und nicht in der freien Wirtschaft Porsche fahren,
und dann brichst du dir Wirtschaft zusammen und dann wird das ja du mein Vater Staat und kannst nicht gekündigt werden und ihr arbeitet da alles wie eine Behörde wahrscheinlich ist der
Punkt das man aus diesen Gründen eben auch beide Systeme irgendwie hat uns versucht die einen Sachen so zu reden die anderen so was aber ein wichtiger Kritikpunkt von Markus ist
bezüglich GEZ wir sehen auch hier einen erfahrenere Semester sagt noch GEZ wie sich das gehört.
Solange die aus dem gebührenfinanzierte Inhalte zu großen Teilen proprietär laufen also nicht unter freien Lizenzen veröffentlicht werden lassen sich die Rundfunkgebühren in meinen Augen nicht rechtfertigen wichtiger.
Ganz also ganz klar ist also nicht diese ganze die Publikation diese ganze Lizensierung das ganze Theater da nicht
akzeptabel das sollte alles irgendwie frei zugänglich sein unter vernünftigen Lizenzen,
diese die Publikation Unsitte
ist aber nicht von denen erfunden worden na das ist ja das haben sie den wurde den Jahr eingeklagt aber natürlich absolut richtig das wäre vielleicht auch echt schön.
Wenn man das invima hinkriegen würde so einen Fall irgendwo anzubringen und und darüber einerseits also im Prinzip die Gebühren anzugreifen und,
dann aber am Ende halt rauszukriegen dass die Gebühren nur gerechtfertigt sind wenn es frei Lizenzen sind und dann da irgendwie dafür zu sorgen dass er sehr schön vielleicht kann ich da jemand mal.
Ja also man das vor allem dann dass ich merk das auch immer öfter dass dass das sozusagen solche Diskussion mit eingebracht wird ist es von impliziter Vorwurf an na ja ihr öffentlich-rechtliche liefert ja noch nicht mal frei würden die wahrscheinlich gerne tun,
ganz klar war das Problem bei denen nicht so klar aber das hat ändert sich auch,
aber der Verhinderer sind halt hier im Wesentlichen wieder unsere Zeitschriftenverlage siehe Leistungsschutzrecht EC die einfach immer wieder Druck auf die Politik ausüben um dort den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk klein zu halten also genau.
Das System was eigentlich jetzt eben auch,
und unsere Diskussionen quasi immer so als korrekt korrektursystem für diese privaten für das private Medien tum Herr gehalten wird ist hier eben auch unter feuer,
und deswegen das spricht er dafür dass ihm noch weiter zu stärken und hier auch ein klares politisches Signal zu setzen sagen ja wir wollen das und wir wollen den nicht nur rechtlich sollen so öffentlich wie es irgendwie geht und es gilt die Politik dahin zu bringen,
das weiter zu unterstützen weiter zu forcieren und eben diese ganzen Inhalte frei zu bekommen das ist natürlich nicht nur ein
Problem mit sa Konkurrenzsituation seiner natürlich greift ja auch das Urheberrecht rein das ist halt über die Jahrzehnte so gewachsen und dann gibt es immer wieder Ausspielung mit wenn das mal wieder ausgestrahlt wird dann bekommen die Autoren,
rechengeld so sind die Verträge gelaufen über lange lange Zeit das muss ich natürlich auch noch ändern
Prinzip haben wir jetzt schon diese Karenzzeit mit Sohn zu lange verbleibt das in der Mediathek und dann passt das auch schon aber um das eben sozusagen lange lange Zeit und dauerhaft online zu haben da muss man sich eben auch komplett neue Vergütungsmodelle,
würdigen.
Jo dann haben wir noch hier.
Eine relativ längliche Beschwerde wir hätten das Google Thema falsch dargestellt,
davon Flaherty,
und zwar sagt er niemand würde sich gegen den AppStore werden wollen das haben wir aber auch nicht gesagt also wahrscheinlich haben wir es gesagt aber nicht gemeint oder so der Wunsch nach der also die PlayStore man will den Google Play Store,
haben
wenn man ein Android Gerät auf den Markt bringt weil das natürlich eine immense Infrastruktur ist uns dort zu unterhalten ja du musst diese Apps prüfen und so weiter nicht habe ja glaube ich auch gestern vorsichtig,
gestern in der letzten Sendung vorsichtig und hörversuch meine,
Geheimhaltungsvereinbarung nicht zu verletzen ein bisschen versucht darüber zu berichten wie das so ist mit dem PlayStore,
und der Android Sicherheit denn entgegen den meisten,
entgegen dem was die meisten wissen wenn ich ja für mehrere Apps im PlayStore verantwortlich aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Der Liebe hat jetzt gesagt du hast irgendwie Android Telefon wird das auf den Markt bringen und jetzt sagst du du willst erneut drauf machen ist er erstmal auf dem Forst und jetzt sagst du,
naja dann will ich deinen AppStore draufhaben ich will aber natürlich selber keinen unterhalten also knote ich diesen App-Store an mein android dran und jetzt Kommentar,
dachte eigentlich das hätten wir sind voll dargestellt haben offenbar nicht denn jetzt sagt Platy dieser Wunsch nachdem nach der PlayStore App wird von Google nun als Hebel genutzt und erhält Stellen an der gleich das gesamte Paket aufzudrücken es gibt eben den PlayStore nicht einzeln
sondern nur im Paket mit einem klebe Vertrag der Chrome als einzigen Browser Google Maps als Karten App und Google als voreingestellte Suchmaschine erzwingen und gleichzeitig verbietet andere Varianten der Geräte komplett
ohne dass Google package auf den Markt zu bringen und das völlig ohne irgendeine technische Notwendigkeit.
Weder aus Usability Sicht nachher,
und so weiter der einzige Grund warum Google das tut ist dass es wirtschaftlich für sie Sinn ergibt wenn Sie den default,
den 95% der Leute aus reiner Faulheit nie ändern auf ihre,
die sitzen können und das ist eben der ja der die Argumentation für die Kartellstrafe mir ist,
habe den einige hätten das ausreichend sind voll dargestellt offenbar ist das nicht der Fall deswegen hier noch mal,
das Feedback kann sein dass uns ein bisschen in Android Sicherheit verloren haben über die ich ja immer
Rand gleichzeitig auch das Problem wenn du dann den irgend so ein f-droid store willst und die Penne ist auch nur auf ihren deine Google library er dann fangen sie wieder an zu quengeln und sagen dass uns hier alles Google frei sein also die verklage ich irgendwann auch noch.
Aber das ist wir haben das Thema behandelt verhält der kann ja weiter Android nutzen ich rate.
Gibt es ich generell bin.
Anderen proprietären Systemen.
Das gibt es wie ich generell bin was soll dieses Android Ökosystemen betreffen ist aber auf jeden Fall sehr
spannendes politisches Auseinandersetzung fällt im bezug auf wie viabel wie anwendungs fähig ist OpenSource eigentlich wirklich im kommerziellen Umfeldern und alles sehr schön das da,
das da soviel Reibungspunkte gibt also schönen Anführungsstrichen um auch mal viele Dinge mal zu klären weil es ist ja immer so ein,
1 1 der mehreren Probleme bei der Anwendung von Open Source und oder generell freier Software wo greift das wo ist es ein Problem wo muss man Abhängigkeiten loswerden wo kann man koexistieren,
warte doch insofern spannendes Feld.
Aber Tim du a******** weißt du was ich dir eigentlich noch sagen wollt.
Was denn du alter Wixer.
Seit 6 Monaten darfst du mich nicht mehr im Internet beleidigen.
Was Schweinerei.
Ja du Wixer,
denn seit sechs Monaten ist das nette g in Kraft und das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz und wir,
erinnern uns zu Beginn gab es ja einige lach haben oder auch nicht lache wegen zu früher wegen wegen,
schöner Beispiele für overblocking z.b. wurde dann auch ein Tweet von Heiko Maas gesperrt der ja für das letzte geh verantwortlich ist weil wo er durch sagt hat beim Besuch der islamischen Gemeinde saarbrücken ist mir gerade wieder klar geworden was für ein Idiot Sarazin ist
klarer Fall von Beleidigung ich weiß allerdings nicht genau ob das
Internet DG gelöscht wurde oder unter genug Leute haben sich darüber beschwert und genau das bleibt auch ein bisschen das,
Problem bei der bei der Berichterstattung über die nun erschienenen berichteten.
Das letzte geht sieht vor dass diese Plattformen die sich dem letzte geh unterwerfen Dinge sperren darüber alle 6 Monate ein Bericht abliefern ja zumindest hier diese größeren Plattform und,
die wurden jetzt veröffentlicht von Facebook Twitter und YouTube,
wir erinnern uns alle diese Plattform haben ja auch schon Möglichkeiten Inhalte die einem nicht gefallen zu,
zu melden und dann werden diese Inhalte vor ihren jeweiligen Community regeln beurteilt und
entsprechend damit verfahren und wenn du jetzt quasi ein Inhalten meldest der gegen deren Community Regeln verstößt dann wird er unter deren Community regeln auch gelöscht,
wenn du aber einen meldest der unter deren Community Regeln nicht anstößig ist,
den sie dann aber dann dann überziehen unterziehen sie in noch einer zweiten Prüfung das ist quasi die
ist der ozd runter das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz und das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz erfaßt ja laut Gesetzestext ausschließlich rechtswidrige Inhalte.
Die ein oder mehreren der folgenden Stadt Tatbestände des Strafgesetzbuchs erfüllen,
Propagandamittel verfassungswidriger Organisationen Kennzeichen verfassungswidriger Organisationen,
Vorbereitung einer schweren staatsgefährdenden Straftat Gewalttat Begehung einer schweren staatsgefährdenden Gewalttat landesverräterische Fälschung Öffentlichkeit zur Aufforderung von Straftat liche Aufforderung zu Straftaten,
Störung des öffentlichen Friedens durch Androhung von Straftaten Bildung krimineller Vereinigung Bildung terroristischer Vereinigung Kriminelle und terroristische Vereinigung im Ausland,
Volksverhetzung Gewaltdarstellung und so weiter und so fort wir wollen euch jetzt gar kein gar nicht auf falsche Gedanken.
Hey du du Arsch du hast Beleidigung vergessen.
Ja das ist sehr kurz danach gekommen Paragraph 185 üble Nachrede reicht aber auch schon Verleumdungen gibt es auch Verletzung des höchstpersönlichen Lebensbereiches durch Bildaufnahmen.
Und so weiter also das Feld würde alles unter das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz fallen vieles davon aber eben auch unter die Community regeln denn das ist ja hier das immer glaube ich einig alles nix was sich gehört.
So und jetzt kommen die also mit ihren Berichten und YouTube sagt na ja wir haben 215.000 Beschwerden bekommen.
Davon haben wir 27% stattgegeben also 68000 Dinge gelöscht
dabei ging es hauptsächlich um Hassrede und politischen Extremismus es ist nicht ganz klar ob es Videos und oder Kommentare wann das ist da wenn ich das richtig sehe nicht
klar ausgewiesen YouTube prüft also doppelt ne einmal Meldefunktion,
überhaupt und dann kann man da eben das Häkchen setzen letzte gehen und nur wenn das nicht unter Lund und Community regeln wird ohnehin einmal,
vorher gemessen geprüft und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage in wie viele von diesen,
23 Meldungen die YouTube nicht wo YouTube nicht im Sinne der meldenden entschieden hat.
Können nun wirklich dafür gewertet werden dass das Problem des overblocking nicht existiert denn
die große Sorge beim netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz war ja dass dadurch dass die Rechtsdurchsetzung hier in private Hände gelegt wird mit der Pistole auf der Brust nämlich es muss innerhalb von 24 Stunden gelöscht werden.
Das dann quasi in Zweifel,
gegen die Angeklagten entschieden wird die Zahl 27% der Beschwerden wurden nur,
umgesetzt legt auf Anhieb erstmal den Schluss nahe dass das nicht der Fall ist allerdings wie wir gleich in den Vergleich zu anderen Netzwerken sehen hat YouTube quasi diese Beschwerde Funktion relativ.
Prominent und einfach umgesetzt und hat die Netz TG Meldungen an der gleichen Stelle wie die.
Wie die Meldungen gemäß Community Regeln also anstoßen anstößigen Inhalt melden zack Klick Häkchen bei netzte geh und fertig ist die Laube.
Insofern könnte es also sein dass im Rahmen der,
irgendwie sinnlosen und aber besonderes wichtigen heiligen Kriege irgendwelche politisch Besessener im Internet hier unter Umständen auch der eine oder andere melde klickt dabei war
der das Ziel hatte einen vielleicht offensichtlich nicht anstößigen Inhalt trotzdem mit irgendeiner Form,
in an der Verbreitung zu hindern denn wenn genug Leute etwas melden dann wird der Inhalt ja auch temporär.
Quasi an der Verbreitung die Verbreitung eingeschränkt vorbehaltlich der Prüfung insofern wie viel nun von diesen zwei Drittel nicht,
angenommenen Meldungen irgendwie halbwegs sinnvolle Wahl
wo YouTube als Retter der Meinungsfreiheit hier sich für die für die Leute die Bresche geschmissen hat und gesagt hat wie er gehen notfalls vor Gericht damit du das sagen kannst oder aus irgendetwas war was ganz eindeutig kein Verstoß ist das ist also nicht,
hier nicht echt in diesem Zahlen erkennbar und vor allem kann man auch diese Zahlen nicht so einfach mit denen zu brenets TG vergleichen sein man kann es einfach nur sagen ok nach Netgear Gigabit 215,
1000 Beschwerden uns ein Drittel davon wurde stattgegeben,
insgesamt haben sie dann 93% der Inhalte die dann gesperrt oder gelöscht werden auch innerhalb von 24 Stunden das heißt sie sind sehr gut an der
relativ nah an der Quote dran weitere Entscheidung haben Sie dann innerhalb einer Woche getroffen und nur bei 860 Fällen 859 dauert es länger als eine Woche.
Und 40 Mal haben sie eine auf Strafe,
spezialisierte externe an,
264000 Beschwerden also noch mal.
Zigtausend mehr als bei YouTube davon aber nur 10% gelöscht,
nämlich 29.000 also etwas über 10% und da stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage,
bei Twitter ist es relativ einfach ein Inhalt zu melden und die haben auch hier das Letzte gehe integriert in ihr bisheriges Meldeformular.
Und.
Wie oft welcher Fall jetzt eintritt dass es quasi unter Community regeln gefallen wäre oder unter ne Ziege Regeln ist ja auch nicht ganz klar erkennbar jetzt kommt das spannende Facebook,
was ja eigentlich hatte ich so den Eindruck dass primär Ding war und um dass ich die gesamte Hassrede Diskussionen,
bewegte na da hatten wir diese mehrere Male war da irgendwie Renate Künast irgendwie Ziel von irgendwelchen Kampanien und Sohn Mann hatte eigentlich immer so ein bisschen Facebook eben.
Im Blick war mein Eindruck.
Na bin ich nicht so sagen ne also ich würde ja ich würde eher sagen so Hass ist eigentlich tatsächlich wirklich ihren Twitter und YouTube Thema
bitte einfach mal abwarten wie das primäre beleidigungs Netzwerk zu sein scheint ohnehin so und ned ich meine Twitter ist ja auch so ein bisschen,
wenn man mal schaut welche Bedeutung diese Netze mittlerweile so für die Gesellschaft errungen haben ne zweifelhafte Errungenschaften teilweise aber so ist es halt gelaufen Twitter ist halt schon so ein bisschen der globale chat,
so ein bisschen der der Ort des Diskurses muss kein guter Diskurs sein aber,
das ist schon das pro fürs benutzt wird nicht nur erst seit Trump aber so dieses Beinhaut mal auf sich ein von daher ist es für mich auch am anfälligsten für diesen eigentlichen,
dieses eigentliche beleidigungs Ding Facebook,
sicherlich auch klar dann fällt das jetzt nicht bei ab aber ich glaube Facebook ist dann doch eher noch ein Problem vor allem so als Fitness Schleuder und Verstärker das sicherlich auch bei der anderen auch mal was dabei und YouTube ist halt nach einfach der Ort,
der Videos und alles was sich halt mit Videos gut abbilden lässt das wird sich dann vielleicht in Zukunft mit facebook auch ändern aber da hat Twitter natürlich überhaupt gar keine Karten ist sehr schwierig ist jetzt auch nur so ein bisschen aus dem Bauch heraus wo die Zahlen überrascht mich jetzt nicht verhält.
Also II sollte ein dann aber doch überraschen weil bei Facebook wurden in dem gleichen Zeitraum 1700 Inhalte gemeldet.
So dass im Vergleich zu irgendwie weit über einer Viertelmillion bei Twitter und das kann ich mir also das lässt sich nicht durch primäres und sekundäres Beleidigung.
Das stimmt.
Erklären sondern das lässt sich erklären weil Facebook nämlich die Meldung nach Netz DG an einem anderen Formular macht als das gegen die gemeinschaftsstandards.
Na na.
Ist ja erinner.
Super das ist meine Facebook war in der Hinsicht schon immer unbenutzbar und.
Genau alles was was irgendwie gesetzlich aufgezwungen ist und irgendwie regulatorische
regulatorische Ketten für YouTube darstellt ist irgendwo zugänglich und in in
LUKB Testung von von Juristen und Psychologen in so positioniert worden dass es auch möglich ist,
niemand in irgendeiner Form finden kann er ist genauso wie diese Privatsphäre-Einstellungen und was nicht alles ne so Facebook kriegt also jetzt 1700 Inhalte,
auf Verstöße gegen das letzte geh gemeldet davon geben Sie 362 statt also sind sie bei 20%,
und erledigen das in der Regel innerhalb von 24 Stunden man könnte also ihr hier auf jeden Fall schonmal sagen bei Facebook versteht keiner wie es geht.
Das ist so ein bisschen BMW manhalter Navi wie sie wussten nicht dass sie ihren Planeten zerstört die Pläne hin noch mehrere Jahre hoffe demnächst den nächstgelegenen Planeten aus AW,
also
so ähnlich läuft das ja ich denke auch das ist einfach vielen überhaupt nicht klar das ganze ist wie ich noch nie Eliten Debatte von daher wird hier auch nicht viel verhindert.
Genau da da und jetzt wird erstmal gefeiert oder oder was heißt gefeiert also Eden Berichterstattung sagt einerseits ja es gibt keine overblocking,
was natürlich ganz interessant ist weil die die 27% könnten ja immer noch overblocking sein.
Dass er geht ja hier überhaupt nicht daraus hervor das bedeuten diese Zahlen überhaupt nicht differenziert was von was für einer Art das war oder wie viel Widerspruch ist wiederum ging das blocking gab also.
Genau und dir einen dir einen meldungs und Ablehnungsquote sind daher einfach nicht aussagekräftig die müssten zumindest ins Verhältnis zu,
früher gesetzt werden bevor es das Gesetz gehabt und dann gabs ja zum also beispielsweise irgendwie jetzt auch kürzlich den Fall von Thomas Stadler
ansonst ist ja auch im Internet law bekannter juristischer Blogger eigentlich für sehr gemäßigt Umgangston bekannt.
Der hatte dann einen Tweet abgesetzt indem er sagte geh endlich sterben menschenverachtender Zyniker
und mit einem Link auf den Zeitungsartikel indem ich ihr Horst Seehofer sah irgendwie stolz erzählte an meinem 69 Geburtstag sind 69 Afghanen abgeschoben worden einer davon ist ja dann irgendwie zwei Tage später gestorben hat er sich nicht mehr so drüber gefreut,
da hat dann also hier der Thomas Stadler eben gesagt geh endlich sterben menschenverachtender Zyniker woraufhin er von Twitter irgendwie gesperrt wurde für einige Zeit da kommt dann so eine so eine Warnung so eine dududu so bitte nicht,
das ist nicht der Umgangston der wir pflegen wollen.
Thomas viel aber natürlich z.b. ist jetzt unklar ob das unterschätzte gefallen ist im Zweifelsfalle nämlich nicht sondern unter Community regeln.
Ja das heißt und jetzt kommt wieder die jetzt kommt wieder die Frage.
Wenn das overblocking unter Umständen nicht wegen des Netze gehst sondern wegen dieser Community Regel Willkür in Anführungszeichen vektorisieren mal als.
Willkürlich festgelegte Community regeln.
Dann ist das ja trotzdem wäre das ja trotzdem noch ein overblocking ja also die Zahlen die wir hier haben reichen sind einfach nicht.
Aussagekräftig für die Frage ob auf den sozialen Netzwerken in der privatisierten rechts ist der Zungen overblocking stattfindet oder nicht das ist einfach mal ein.
Weißt du weißt du eigentlich ob das ein ob ob es eine im Netz DG sozusagen eine Dokumentationspflicht für diese Unternehmen gibt also eine.
Genau deswegen gibt's jetzt gerade von drei Unternehmen genau nach sechs Monaten diese Berichte die das des müssen die.
Aber so differenziert scheint das ja nicht zu sein dass man daraus wirklich was raus lesen kann.
Na ja die haben sich halt mit Sicherheit die Werte berichtet die sie zu berichten haben und nat,
es sind diejenigen die jetzt hier irgendwie ansprechen hat erstmal so viel für sich und es ist als liegt natürlich auch die die Interpretation durchaus nahezu sagen na ja
Facebook entspricht 20% 14 % YouTube 27%,
mit anderen Worten es werden immer nur jeder dritte gemeldete Inhalt wird gelöscht,
da ist auf jeden Fall so liegt der Verdacht nahe dass es sich eben nicht um overblocking handelt wenn man dann aber eben schaut na ja die gehen auch noch mal nach ihren eigenen Community-Richtlinien und die sind davon wiederum ausgenommen das heißt man könnte,
hat den Verdacht haben.
Dass der größere Teil der Sinn der nachdem letzte g verboten ist auch nachdem Community regeln verboten wäre mit anderen Worten schon am Community Regel Filter hängen bleibt,
und nur das was da nicht ohnehin schon an den Regeln die sie hatten hängengeblieben ist,
gehe dann noch mal in den letzte gefilter und für dazu vollständig anderen Zahlen nämlich,
abzüglich dessen was sie ohnehin schon tun und da da da diese Prozesse so sind sind eben auch die die daraus herauskommen in Zahlen eben als solche nicht interpretierbar. Warum glaube ich auch nicht weiter zu Disco,
jetzt kommt der also man weiß natürlich auswendig top
vielleicht die Unternehmen auch gesagt haben na ja okay wir hatten wir sehen ja dass das Gesetz zu relativ wenig Rückhalt hat und entsprechend ändern wir unsere Entscheidung SMAS unsere Entscheidungsregeln oder sonstiges
aber spannend ist was bedeutet das für das Gesetz selber man könnte also jetzt sagen das netzdg hat dazu geführt dass auf in einem halben Jahr.
Auf Twitter 29001 gelöscht auf Facebook 362 Beiträge gelöscht und auf YouTube 68000 Beiträge gelöscht wurden so ist das jetzt ein Erfolg oder nicht.
Leben fühlt sich gleich viel friedlicher an.
Genau ich will für mich auch direkt frivoler im Internet und wir in uns aber auch an die Berichte von einem Bericht von Richard Gutjahr
der ja irgendwie seit einigen Jahren inzwischen da mit solchen Verschwörungstheoretikern zu tun hatten am am Anfang war das ja noch amüsant aber inzwischen war das jetzt
ausgeartet zu sein richtigen Terrorismus gegen ihn und seine Familie.
Haben wir damals auch drüber berichtet das war der der ist Journalist auch bei der ARD glaube ich oder ich weiß ob der freie Journalist ist.
Der arbeitet glaube ich für verschiedene Zoom.
Verschiedene ne der war als in war das in Frankreich Nizza oder dieser LKW der in die Menschenmenge.
Die Terrorattacke wo der LKW reingefahren ist der stand halt zufällig da am Balkon an seinem Zimmer hat das gefilmt und dann gepostet und dieser Zufall ja das wurde ihm dann sozusagen als erstes.
Nee nee der wurde ihm noch nicht zur Last gelegt für Last wurde ihm gelegt dass er in München wohnt und als dann mehrere Monate später in München irgendwann,
durchgeknallt herum rannte mit der Knarre er wie ist der Zufall will als Münchner Bürger leben in der Nähe war.
Und dann da auch Bericht erstattet hat und dann haben halt irgendwie ein paar Leute die mit dem Mathematikunterricht den hat auch nur gemacht haben damit sie beim Brötchen holen das Wechselgeld prüfen können haben halt dann irgendwie sich in der Stochastik,
er versucht und ausgerechnet dass der Richard gut hier in der Zwischenzeit zehnmal hätte vom Blitz getroffen hätten müssen.
Und das auch noch alles überlebt hat und deswegen ist aber ein BMW oder so ne also totaler Schluss
der hat aber das ist das entscheidende hat damals gesagt sein Problem wurde nicht gelöst durch dieses durch dieses netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz nehme ich dass dir den Scheiß immer wieder in abgewandelter Form immer wieder neu hochgeladen haben,
aber sein Anwalt wenn ich mich recht entsinne Markus Kompa hat immerhin gesagt na ist doch schön
immerhin dank netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz muss müssen die Adressen in Deutschland vorhalten an die wir uns wenden können jetzt kommt der Eco Bundesverband der Internetwirtschaft nicht Bundesverband und sagt,
das Netze die ist und bleibt ein überflüssiges gesetzt und eine Bedrohung für die Meinungsfreiheit Meinungsfreiheit im Netz sagt Oliver süme
die heute veröffentlichen Transparenzgesetz it's a Transparenzberichte zeigen dass ich dass das lösch aufkommen wird das netzdg nicht maßgeblich verändert hat,
Unternehmen löschen von mehr als noch vor einigen Jahren dies aber nicht auf,
das Gesetz sondern auf extrem verbessert dieses ehrlich auf das Gesetz von auf extrem verbesserte Technologien sowie ein gesteigertes Problembewusstsein bei den Unternehmen zurück.
Meldung zum Netze G4 in der Gesamtbilanz kaum ins Gewicht so also der Verband der Internetwirtschaft in Deutsch.
Na also man könnte abschließend sagen er nicht alles was unsinnig ist nicht nicht die nicht die aller schlimmsten Befürchtungen
haben sich bewahrheitet das heißt noch lange nicht dass das jetzt irgendwie gute Idee war ne also wenn man sagt etwas hat nur zu nicht nicht ganz so hohen Schaden geführt wie wir dachten.
Und er weiß sich in der,
in der Menge als größtenteils nicht sinnvolle Ergänzung dann heißt es eben noch lange nicht dass es jetzt unbedingt gut zu feiern ist Heiko Maas und dann noch in seiner Rolle als Justizminister hinterlassen.
Solinus ich war ja weitgehend offen im Off.
Ich habe gehört dass die Störerhaftung einen Realitätscheck bekommen hat und vom Bundesgerichtshof gelandet ist da gab es doch jetzt ein Urteil.
Richtig ja also das auch wieder Ferien ein komplizierter Fall ich hoffe ich kriege den grob hin es handelt sich um einen Fall von zwei in der im Jahre 2013 statt fahren.
So da hat jemand über eine Internet Tauschbörse ein Spiel zum Herunterladen angeboten und jetzt fand sich vor Gericht wieder,
jemand der mehrere offene WLANs sowie zwei Tor exit nodes unterhalten hat,
und über diese Tor exit nodes wurde eben ein Spiel zum herunterladen Angebot,
jetzt ist natürlich wieder also wir mir jetzt nicht ganz glaube ich vermute da hat also jemand,
BitTorrent über Tor gemacht was ich eigentlich nicht empfiehlt aber ein anderes Thema.
Und so landete dann die IP-Adresse der Tor exit Node in denen IP-address Sammelstellen,
der Rechteverwerter die sich ja mit einem dir einfach an den Thorens mit teilnehmen und daneben automatisiert die Serienbriefe rauschig.
Das wurde diskutiert vor dem Oberlandesgericht Düsseldorf und da stellte sich nun in diesem Verfahren das in irgendeiner das natürlich ein bisschen komplexer ist die Frage ob die Störerhaftung Aufhebung,
die ja von Seiten der Bundesregierung wenn ich mich nicht täusche letztes Jahr stattgefunden hat mit dem EU-Recht vereinbar ist.
Und.
Damit ging dieser ganze Fall vor dem BGH der jetzt eigentlich diese Frage beantworten wollte aber gleichzeitig jetzt sagte naja nach diesem neuen Gesetz gilt für diesen Beschuldigten hier,
keine Haftung als Störer ja also dadurch dass er oder sie einen eine Tor exit Nord,
eingerichtet hat ist sie nicht als Störer rin in die Haftung zu nehmen weil irgendjemand anders und kein Anspruch name dieses dieser Tor exit Nord eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen hat,
also man könnte jetzt als Twitter Journalist schnell zu dem Ergebnis kommen ja die Störerhaftung die Abschaffung der Störerhaftung wurde durch den BGH bestätigt das stimmt erstmal,
aber sagt der BGH die Geschädigte Partei hat immer noch einen Speer Anspruch.
Gegenüber der Betreiberin dieser exit Note.
Obwohl gerade festgestellt wurde dass sie nicht haftbar gemacht werden.
Genau Haftung ist ja was anderes Haftung heiße erstmal,
doudna wir können den wir können die Täterin nicht feststellen hier das Computerspiel angeboten hat deswegen machen wir dich jetzt als Betreiberin der exit not haftbar für das schändliche betreiben dieser exit Nord du bezahlst jetzt die Abmahnung,
das geht ja gar nicht sagte BGH nee geht nicht also keine Straftat aber sperr Anspruch und sagt also nach den Revisionsrecht lich einwandfrei Einverständnis Oberlandesgericht ist die Sperrung von Filesharing Software technisch möglich,
und den Beklagten zumutbar.
Und gibt das damit zurück ans OLG Düsseldorf und das kann nun entscheiden welche Sperrmaßnahmen in Frage kommen,
dabei kann sich das OLG nun auf also wenn man jetzt,
auf dieses Störerhaftung es aufhebungsgesetz Bezug nimmt könnte man quasi zitieren,
Passwort Zugangsschutz lässt sich beim Tor exit nur bedingt.
Oder aber z.b. auf spezifische Sperren von Ports und.
Jetzt sagt der BGH dazu weiterhin der Anspruch auf Sperrmaßnahmen.
Ist nicht auf bestimmte Sperrmaßnahmen beschränkt und kann auch die Pflicht,
zur Registrierung von Nutzern zur Verschlüsselung des Zugangs mit einem Passwort oder im äußersten Fall zur vollständigen Sperrung des Zugangs umfassen
so das ist natürlich jetzt alles hier auf WLAN gemünzt na also du kannst sagen nachher ok wir machen eine Nutzerregistrierung in unserem WLAN wir machen wir sperren der Tauschbörsen in unserem WLAN oder wir Leute müssen sich
registrieren in unserem WLAN bei einem Tor exit geht das natürlich nicht so einfach also zusagt willkommen bei unserem Tor exit bitte bitte geben Sie in ihren Nutzernamen an,
das kannst du zwar so machen dann wird ein Tor exit aber relativ schnell nicht mehr innerhalb des Tor Netzwerk advertised werden
und dann wird halt niemand mehr in Dammtor exit rauskommen weil das ja als eine zurecht als eine Manipulation des Traffics.
Ja das widerspricht halt auch einfach der Idee von Tor halt hier
Prüfer Privatsphäre zu sichern und die Quellen zu verschleiern das ist eigentlich vollkommen absurd gegenüber ein Tor exit not überhaupt so von seiner Sperrungen zu sprechen weil man da eh nicht weiß was da raus fällt und heute ist Beton morgen,
irgendwie ein wichtiger click.
Kannst aber natürlich das ist wenn du einen Tor exit konfiguriert kannst du eine exit policy benennen und diese
diese exe policy kann z.b. so was beinhalten wie ich hier nur Port 80 raus oder hier nur Port 443 raus,
oder hier nur
port25 bzw der Regel macht hat sich das Gegenteil weil du keine Spamschleuder werden möchtest und sagst halt hier port25 ausgeht mach mal bitte nicht weil,
ist doof.
Geh du bist nichts beim raus.
Genau du kannst also in Corinto rauf Ports limitieren,
oder du kannst auch spezifische portsperre nentor das kann unterschiedliche Gründe haben du kannst ja z.b. sagen dieser exit den ich jetzt hier betreibe der soll spezifisch dem Ziel dienen,
Leuten anonymen Zugang zum ERC zu ermöglichen und deswegen mache ich hier nur ERC damit ich möglichst viele ihre Zähne nutze auf meinem exit habe oder so ne wäre ja wäre alles möglich.
Sofern dieser ERC auch immer nur mit standardisierten Ports arbeitet aber es kann man ja auch nicht so ohne weiteres sicher.
Ja ja du könntest halt sagen auf nicht Standard wäre eben jetzt hier auf nicht Standardports tut sich eben bei mir,
nicht rauskommen damit das sagt das sagt das ist eben eine Eigenschaft deines Tor exit und die wird natürlich auch innerhalb des Tor-Netzwerk bekanntgegeben so dass wenn jemand woanders hin will er einfach nicht auf deinen exit kommt.
Und BitTorrent aber wiederum wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche mach den größeren Teil des Traffics in Judy P und auf allen Ports die der die der bitt Gott geschaffen hat.
Weil man kann nicht so konfigurieren dass ich immer random mäßig einen anderen nimmt ca das gibt es mal so mal so der benutzt jetzt nicht alle gleichzeitig aber er benutzt halt immer mal wieder andere.
Sehr natürlich jetzt irgendwie.
Also das wird jetzt eben so zurückgegeben entscheidend ist dass das OLG kann jetzt alles machen zwischen.
Naja Sperre bitte unter unterbinde die Tauschbörse Nutzung durch deinen exit not.
Sie können aber natürlich auch also bei bei ausreichend mangelhaft da Kompetenz können sie aussagen machte deinen exit halt jetzt irgendwie eine Sperre,
du musst jetzt mach eine Zugangssperre man darf nur noch an nur noch angemeldete Nutzer dürfen dein tor11 exit nutzen oder so.
Und dann wäre natürlich die,
die Frage wenn ihr diese Sperre die verlangte Sperre nicht umsetzt ob er dann nicht wiederum in irgendeiner Form doch in in Regress genommen werden könnte aber das so weit sind wir noch nicht.
Und wir werden jetzt sehen was das Oberlandesgericht Düsseldorf und dazu urteilt für Tor ist das auf jeden Fall ne
haarige Angelegenheit ehrlich gesagt weil wenn das jetzt heißt wenn der jetzt auf einmal gesagt wird naja es kann jemand verlangen dass du auf deinen Tor exit bestimmte Port sperrst und die Nutzung bestimmter Dinge verhinderst dann wird es auf jeden Fall noch mal richtig knatschig.
Ja boah also dem Artikel von Stadler.
Ist das richtig deute Maintal na ja im Wesentlichen wird ja aber auch wäre wohl auch bitte alten Gesetzgebung nicht sehr viel anderes bei rausgekommen.
Ich frage mich jetzt gerade nur ob das jetzt hier noch eine Chance hat noch mal vom Olli Haare noch mal angerufen zu werden dass man könnte ja im Prinzip ist vom BGH noch mal weg eskalieren weiß jetzt nicht ob ich eine Revision Ausschluss besteht.
Geradezu ständig raus.
Wir schauen einfach mal wie das weitergeht zunächst wird es auf jeden Fall jetzt andere an das OLG Düsseldorf gehen und Thomas Stadler sagt er dazu so im Prinzip ist es dann halt die die Störerhaftung in mit anderen mit anderen Mitteln.
Na gut Fortsetzung.
Fortsetzung wir schauen wie es ist also zum allzu viel zu feiern gibt über dieses Wetter erstmal nicht.
Gute Mahlzeit noch ein paar kleine Kurzmeldung.
Genau wir haben Kurzmeldung es ist jetzt.
Seid seit acht Jahren ist unser Freund Rudi oa Sanchez nicht mehr frei frei im Sinne von kann sich ihr hin bewegen wohin er möchte.
Es ging los das muss glaube ich 2010 gewesen sein mit den Vorwürfen.
Bestimmter sexueller Vergehen der war verschiedene Straftatbestände zwischen Vergewaltigung.
Belästigung und so weiter je nachdem nach welchem ist Strafgesetzbuch man das interpretiert erhoben worden von wenn ich mich recht entsinne zwei unterschiedlichen Frauen.
Den Schweden genau.
In Schweden so die schwedischen Behörden machen sich dann da darauf,
in dieser Angelegenheit zu ermitteln und hatten einen internationalen Haftbefehl oder ein suche quasi herausgegeben weil sie sich gerne mit Herrn Assange unterhalten wollen würden da war er aber noch nicht offiziell eines.
Einer Straftat beschuldigt worden.
Nur Ermittlungen.
Also genau es wurde immer noch nicht angeklagt es wurde nur gegen ihn ermittelt ja ging ging Leute ermittelt werden kann in jeder kann,
passiert am laufenden Band ja wenn ich den Tim gleich Anzeige weil der hier mich am Anfang der Sendung beleidigt hat er wird gegen den Tim ermittelt.
Du hast mich beleidigt.
Deine Mutter hat dich.
Ja, nicht so.
Und dann so und jetzt.
Schule GH.
Und jetzt.
Es war ja die Argumentation von Schweden, bitte her wir wollen es mit dir unterhalten wir haben ihren legitimen Anspruch und mit dir zu unterhalten und dann hat Assange argumentiert und wie sinnvoll diese Argumentation ist darüber scheiden sich die Geister hat gesagt das auf
in dem Moment wo ich in Schweden bin flattert bei euch irgendein Auslieferungsgesuch der USA ein deswegen möchte ich nicht nackt Schweden ich fühle mich hier in Großbritannien sicher,
deswegen befragt mich doch bitte hier und das ist irgendwie dann aber nicht geschehen dann hatte Großbritannien in eigentlich unter Hausarrest gesetzt dann ist er irgendwann in die ecuadorianische Botschaft geflohen und hat sich dort,
hat dort Asyl beantragt welches ihm gewährt wurde und dann war eben als Asyl,
suchen da oder als Asyl politisch Asyl bis BA Süd Herr Ecuadorianer in dieser.
Als Asyl Tourist.
Als Asyl Tourist vor.
Seitdem wohnte der als Asyl Tourist in London in der ecuadorianischen Botschaft direkt beim Harrods man würde sagen gute Lage,
Zweizimmerwohnung mit Balkon von dem Balkon hat er dann auch öfter runter gesprochen zu seinen Fans und vor der Türsteher Stand seit seiner Seite weiß ich wie viel Jahren jetzt der Polizei.
Zwischenzeitlich wurde in.
Ist das schon Korea es ist aber in Ecuador neu gewählt denn der Präsident von Ecuador hieß früher Rafael Correa und jetzt heißt der Präsident Lenin Moreno.
Lehnin Lehnin.
Also die haben echt Lehnin Lehnin Lehnin.
Halt deine.
Tierfilme geile Namen Korea Lehnin Lehnin Lehnin hatir.
Also Herr Moreno.
Lenin hat jetzt gesagt lenin war vor einigen Wochen in Großbritannien hatte eigentlich auf ihrem Gipfel,
gesprochen bei der Gelegenheit aber auch mit denen Spanien sich unterhalten denn die Spanier waren ja auch knatschig weil es hat sich irgendwie ausführlich in diese Diskussion um den putschdemon,
eingemischt hatte.
Putschdemon.
Butte Montana das ist der katalonische befreiungs führer.
Ja aber das ist gerade ausgesprochen wie Putsch Strich Dämon.
So wird das ausgesprochen leichter uk-nord an hier bist.
Der putzstell Mader.
Freund wies mich darauf hin ich sag jetzt einen Namen nicht aber er sei freundlich gegrüßt das dass dass das immer wie putzt man ausgesprochen wird und wenn das einmal so gefragt ist sind.
Aber seit drei Monaten haben die dem da schon das Internet abgestellt was heißt dass er die.
Beziehung zwischen der Botschaft und ihren ihrem Couchsurfer da inzwischen eh so ein bisschen schlechter sind und jetzt hat der Linien eben auch gesagt na ja in den nächsten Wochen kriegt er hier den Stiefel und dann übergeben wir den.
Den UK Behörden die auch schon länger vor der Tür.
Jetzt ist sie so das heißt für die Situation von Julien SVT ist jetzt seit ungefähr acht Jahren in seiner Bewegungsfreiheit eingeschränkt ohne offiziell eines Verbrechens angeklagt oder auch nur beschuldigt worden zu sein.
Moment Moment Moment das stimmt natürlich nicht genau er ist in seiner Bewegungsfreiheit nicht eingeschränkt als er erkannte jederzeit rausgehen.
Ja ein denn er hatte ja er wäre ja dann würde er der dem der Aufenthalts und Meldeauflage Großbritanniens unterliegen die ihn ja eigentlich gerne auf seiner Ranch da draußen in Sussex oder Bolivar.
Atemblockade Hausarrest geht wahrscheinlich noch ne das Handy.
Ja der gilt noch und das ist auch übrigens der eins der einzige tatsächliche Verstoß der gegen ihn erhoben wird und erhoben werden kann nach britischem Recht helye to surrender.
Und damit dessen hat er sich eben schuldig gemacht indem er gegen seine kautions Auflagen da verstoßen hat nämlich nicht mit seiner Fußfessel auf der Ranch geblieben ist,
sondern wir erinnern uns an die LMP Folge mit dem Titel einmal Asyl und eine Flex bitte denn er ist ja mit seiner mit seiner mit seinem Fußfessel daneben des Nachts,
nach London gefahren so darauf stehen drei Monate plus Geld.
Die könnten aber auch die britische Justiz könnte aber auch argumentieren dass er das quasi besorgt auf besonders heimtückische Weise,
er getan hat und dann wäre die würden sie ihn wegen contempt of court.
Also ich in Ark wohnen gegenüber dem Gericht oder sowas ne würde man das glaube ich übersetzen gebe ich weiß gibt sicherlich auch nicht.
Ja Missachtung ja.
Missachtung des Gerichtes genau Missachtung des Gerichtes da Stunden bis zu zwei Jahre Haft drauf.
Das heißt da würden sie eh noch mal irgendwie verhandeln ne.
Aber selbst wenn die wenn sie das alles machen und das nur nach britischem Recht da abgehandelt wird dann wäre er da aus der Nummer raus denn im Mai 2017 hat Schweden schon die Ermittlungen wegen seiner sexuellen vergehen,
eingestellt weil sie sagen soll dass ich jetzt irgendwie sieben Jahre her der Typ sperrt sich gegen die Befragung,
Erforscher natürlich immer argumentiert ihr Schwert euch gegen meine Auflagen für eine Befragung und.
Das der Verfahren ist also eingestellt mit anderen Worten da gibt's keinen.
Kein Auslieferungs Befehl keinen Haftbefehl mehr von schwedischer Seite des heißt der würde im Zweifelsfall jetzt eben nur noch nach UK recht
da abgeholt hat werden dann würde ihm maximal noch zwei Jahre blühen dann könnte man natürlich argumentieren ey die zwei Jahre hat er doch eh jetzt schon in ihn nicht in Freiheit verbracht und man könnte also damit rechnen dass das noch mal längere rechtliche Auseinandersetzung wird.
Frage ist aber was macht der Ami.
Mit dem ICE wieso wenn es nur nach Trump gehen würde man ja sagen naja Trump begnadigt den und dann ist alles gut ja aber Trump hat ja schon längere Zeit jetzt auf wegen seiner ewigen
Russland IEEE Russland Nähe hin und her zu Hause auch ordentlich knarrt das heißt so eine.
Und dieses ganze Russia didn't matter in the election Thema ist ja in Großweil in in in den USA gerade groß,
das heißt es gäbe gute Gründe dass ich hier er z.b. auf seinen it funny General den Chefankläger Jeff sessions hört der schon öfter gesagt hat dass er
schalte die Obama Politik auf,
Quellen und Whistleblower einzubrechen und sie mit der ganzen Härte des Gesetzes zu konfrontieren,
weiterführen möchte ja und dass er ja auch in die gegen Medienhäuser klagen möchte und so weiter und oder er könnte auf Mike Pompeo hören.
Der Ehe schon Wikileaks als nicht staatlicher bösartiger Geheimdienst der sich gerne von Russland einspannen lässt bezeichnet hat,
und das heißt er könnte also auch Schärfe,
walten lasse ich werde dich natürlich gegen jegliche Auslieferungsverfahren,
wären das heißt dann hätten wir da irgendwelche so britische Auslieferungsverfahren Dinge und so weiter wir werden mal sehen wie das da wie das da geht,
kommt ein bisschen darauf an wie wahnsinnig alle Beteiligten entscheiden.
Sein zu wollen da wir aber jetzt hier in dieser Russland Debatte auch gesehen haben das ja am Ende wer war da noch mal vor Gericht das war doch der peinlich vor Gericht von.
Vor dem Kongress das war doch der
Piona Mike Pompeo der da mehrere Stunden ausgesagt hatte der letztendlich durch die Blume gesagt hat kümmert euch mal nicht darum was der Präsident füttert seiner kümmert euch darum was die Regierung macht und da ist natürlich er davon auszugehen dass sie sich den,
schnapp.
Na ja weiß ich nicht ich meine Trump könnte es ja nun im Rahmen dieser Russland Untersuchungen sind ja auch diese ganzen hin und her Geschichten zwischen,
timezone.
Und Wikileaks ja da gab es diesen intensiven Twitter DM Austausch mit Absprache über Veröffentlichung von Material DTZ mir schon,
schön dass Sie drum Familien Interesse daran hat den Assange auch noch außerhalb der Befragung Reichweite von Robert maaser zu halten.
Beginner es könnte durchaus sein dass am Ende der dermalight in den Arsch nach USA holen wir werden wir werden es gespannt erwarten es auf jeden Fall,
also diese Situation in der ecuadorianischen Botschaft wird also auf die ein oder auf die andere Weise nun langsam zu einem Ende kommen was das in den in Großbritannien bedeutet haben wir erläutert was das dann aber in,
noch bedeutet wenn andere Länder nun ihre indightment aus der Schublade holen werden wir eben dann,
erleben es bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend.
Das ist richtig.
Weißt du was aber noch spannender.
Ja Wettbewerbe.
Didi IFG Meisterschaft.
Ja genau die hat mir schon mal hatten wir schon mal drüber gesprochen wenn man gerade.
Ja Anne hat sie bei uns noch mal erklärt in der LMP2 106.
Hast du bei der loquo Netzpolitik 256 richtig genau also in der normalen sind und was nicht drin aber natürlich in unserem Spezial das habt ihr ja sicherlich alle gehört genau EFG also es geht hier um das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz,
und die ESG Meisterschaften wurden von Arne glaube ich wesentlichen ausgerufen ne.
Genau das funktioniert wie ein Turnier es fangen,
wie viele 18 Ministerien gibt es ne fang an und dann geht's im ausscheide Verfahren immer quasi in jeder Runde weiter wär welches der bei welches der beiden Ministerien zuerst ein Dokument vollständig herausgibt gewinnt,
geben beide Ministerien nur Teile eines Dokumentes heraus gewinnt das Ministerium mit weniger Schwärzungen.
Ist auch hier Gleichstand entscheidet die Geschwindigkeit der Antwort,
wer nicht innerhalb der einmonatigen Frist antwortet wird disqualifiziert und na angefangen hat es eben mit denen mit mit allen Giganten ja um,
in 2 4 6 8 9 10 12 14 16 Ministerien richtig zählen.
8 und 16 Jahre und dann quasi in der in der zweiten Runde traten dann also Frank-Walter Steinmeier Meister gegen Julia Klöckl an Anja Karliczek gegen Svenja Schulze Horst Seehofer gegen Ursula von der Leyen,
Heiko Maas gegen andreas Scheuer und dann im Halbfinale standen Heiko Maas gegen Horst Seehofer und Julia Klöckner gegen Anja Karliczek.
Also man muss dazu sagen das sind jetzt die die Leiter der jeweiligen Organisationen um die es geht ne also Auswärtiges Abend und in Ministerium.
Genau und im und im Finale stehen jetzt Heiko Maas Auswärtiges Amt der sich im Halbfinale gegen Horst Seehofer durchsetzen konnte,
und Anja Karliczek vom BMBF die sich eben im Halbfinale gegen Julia Klöckner durchsetzen konnte.
Also das heißt das jetzt quasi Heiko Maas bisher immer früher geantwortet hat.
Heiko Maas konnte sich in in 1. in in in der in der ersten Runde gegen Gerd Müller durchsetzen dann gegen andreas Scheuer und dann im Halbfinale gegen Horst Seehofer und steht hier im Endspiel.
Ja gut aber wenn ich die Regeln jetzt richtig verstanden habe bedeutet das dass sein Institut schneller geliefert hat.
Schneller und transparenter.
Also am Ende ist eigentlich der Gewinner steht relativ gut da.
Der Gewinner hat in den in jeweils in diesen Monaten.
Es ist jetzt kein weil ich glaube es gibt gleich auch das Missverständnis dass es so tanken Negativpreis ist dass derjenige gewinnt der.
Nein nein nein.
Der Sultan am schlechtesten liefert aber das ist.
Ja natürlich habe die ich habe hier Ringe doch gerade erklärt wir sind hier.
Ja aber.
Wir sind ja beim internationalen Turnier hier gewinnt natürlich der beste.
Hast du eine zweite Liga ist das anders oder Fest der Gewinne die schlechtesten.
Siehst du doch werden häufig nicht.
Das stimmt dann pauli und Union sind immer noch nicht weiter.
Schön war natürlich auch ist dann die die Runden war ja auch immer Unterthemen.
Also Achtelfinale ging es um interne Weisungen im Viertelfinale ging es um Geschenke Verzeichnisse im Halbfinale ging es um um Kunst und jetzt geht es,
und Webside Statistiken wer gibt die Statistiken der Ministeriums Webseiten zuerst heraus wer wird transparent Siegerin 20,
wenn wir also jetzt sehen werde wer da sich durchsetzt und es bleibt natürlich spannend das Duell der Giganten und wir sind sehr gespannt wie das da weiter.
Na gut viel Spaß noch.
Weniger Spannung wie es weitergeht wird bei der e-privacy-verordnung geben wir erinnern uns die e-privacy-verordnung ist er quasi ein weiteres,
EU
analog zur eu-datenschutz-grundverordnung nämlich im Internet dafür zu sorgen dass,
für das tracking eine Zustimmung verlangt werden muss,
das Browser und Mobilgeräte immer per Default auf den schärfsten Privatsphäre-Einstellungen voreingestellt sein müssen und dass die Rechte von Nutzerinnen und Nutzern gegenüber den Anbietern im Internet,
stärker ausgebaut werden und das ist natürlich etwas was die ganze die die werbe.
Und Tracking basierte Industrie überhaupt nicht gut finden kann,
allen voran Mathias Döpfner vom Springer Verlag der die e-privacy Reform,
als die Taliban Variante des Datenschutzes bezeichnet hat und ich weiß wer da weißt du dann weißt du dass du irgendwas richtig gemacht.
Eröffnen wenn du so wenn du so hohl so Hohenadel.
Ja genau wenn wenn ich schon so weit ausholen dann geht's in die richtige Richtung.
Na ja und jetzt hat die österreichische Regierung den Vorsitz im Rat das geht ja streng reihum mir das halbe Jahr glaube ich und die haben erstmal gesagt sie ja nee also während unserer werden unseres Ratsvorsitz ist.
Diese Sache also die Einigung dem Trilog jetzt erstmal nicht auf unseren unseren.
Prioritäten das heißt das irgendwie vor 20:20 Uhr das Ding noch verabschiedet wird ist jetzt erstmal.
Äußerst unwahrscheinlich und das.
Familien das komplett in der Hand.
Na die können ja schon ihre Agenda im Vorsitz bestimmen sollen die haben das jetzt erstmal nicht oben hin getan und die die Diskussion frisst forsen,
oder überhaupt die arbeitsressourcen sind ja ja beschränkt und wenn die sagen wir priorisieren ist erstmal was anderes dann ist das jetzt erst.
Gut aber ich meinte solche solche Gesetzes Pläne und und und Wanda was wo wie beschlossen werden soll das ist ja sozusagen nicht im etwas was immer im Rahmen einer einzigen Ratspräsidentschaft abgefeiert wird sondern diese ganzen,
Prozesse sind ja meistens über.
Über die volle Zeit der Legislaturperiode hin definiert das heißt man hatte halt auch bei der e-privacy-verordnung erwartet dass das eben im Rahmen der aktuellen Legislatur,
abgewickelt werden wird darauf sind ja alle Zeitpläne eingestellt eigentlich jetzt weiß ich nicht inwiefern die Österreicher an der Stelle jetzt noch Gegenwind bekommen.
Aufgeschoben heißt ja nicht aufgehoben.
Nee aber ich meinte das bedeutet dass es alles mit.
Herbeigeführt werden und Österreich hat das jetzt gerade nicht als Priorität.
Ja gut aber was hast du das sind ja jetzt nicht nur kommt Ninja später sondern das bedeutet ja auch kommt nach der nächsten Europawahl,
also das heißt das Feld muss komplett neu aufgerollt werden weil er packt alle Leute die daran gearbeitet haben,
und dir auch in dem Kontext quasi im Parlament auch an der aktuellen datenschutzgrundverordnung mitgewirkt haben also nicht alle aber wieder zumindest sind dann halt unter Umständen nicht mehr da.
Unter die nächste Europawahl verspricht ohnehin ganz sportlich zu werden was Änderungen im Parlament betrifft.
Ja
Fury gerade einen schönen Podcast du veröffentlicht genau zu diesem Thema also der Europawahl im nächsten Jahr,
bei Focus Europa, noch mal verlängern.
Masini Shownotes.
Hand und ich mal dass sie e-privacy-verordnung verzögert wird ist ja länger her dass wir Ingo dachwitz zu dem Thema bei uns hatten Lehre der Körper nicht fühlt sich der jetzt auch hier drüber natürlich berichtet.
Na das sagte sagte.
Prall datenschutz-grundverordnung so ist vergingen fast zwei Jahre seitdem die EU-Kommission ihren Vorschlag für die Verordnung vorgestellt hatte dann hat das EU-Parlament unter enormen Zeitdruck,
2000 Moment,
seine Position zu Reform im Oktober 2017 beschlossen und dann lad Bulgarien im Frühjahr 2018 ein Kompromissvorschlag im Rat vorgelegt mit dem viele Länder hätten arbeiten können.
Mit Deutschland positionierte sich im Juli dieses Jahres endlich auch der letzte große Player im Rat endlich stünde einer Einigung also nichts mehr im Wege.
Und dann geht als die österreichische,
Regierung hin und sagt ach ja da brauchen wir gar keinen Verhandlungsmandat erreichen das ist es ist können wir ruhig noch mal alles liegen lassen obwohl jetzt hier zwei Jahre Arbeit drin stecken und alle eigentlich bereite.
Also da bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher ob die damit durchkommen ganz ehrlich,
aber ich glaube da wird der Widerstand im Parlament schon krass sein und dass die Österreicher jetzt nicht unbedingt als besonders proeuropäisch eingestellt gelten dürfte auch kein Geheimnis sein also da weiß ich nicht ob der Drops da schon gelutscht ist das wird sicherlich eine Menge Widerstand geben.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall Protest von ihrem Video Petry also European Digittrade Access no privacy international und 3T political Association of Denmark dir also sagen wir wollen das hier schneller haben.
Aber da sehen wir mal wieder nicht alles was aus Österreich kommt.
Ich meinte damit natürlich jetzt hier Thomas.
Ja klar hallo Thomas.
Über dann noch letzte kleine Scherz Meldungen als Donald Trump und.
Wladimir Putin sich in Helsinki trafen überreichte Donald Trump überreichte Putin natürlich auch ein Geschenk an Donald Trump und was sollte es da Schöneres sein als,
Fußball anlässlich der ja gerade dort stattgefunden haben denn Fußball-WM.
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft.
Muss ja nicht so richtig was mit anzufangen mit dem mit dem Ball naja.
Naja so und Wespe solche solche Geschenke werden üblicherweise geprüft auf ne
geben die Radio Emissionen ab ist da irgendwas drin ist dann sind wir halt einfach mal kurz dem dem dem Wahnsinn Test unterzogen.
Und stellte sich raus indem in dem Fußballverein NFC-Chip der zur Installation einer App auffordert und.
NFC also ein ein NFC-Tag tschuldigung nicht an NFC-Chip sondern eine NFC-Tag.
Ja es ist ein Schiff aber es hat es hat
in entscheidenden Unterschied nämlich ein NFC-Tags sendet einfach nur immer das gleiche aus und die haben halt irgendwie adidas hatte in diesem Ball halt das hat dieser Ball nun mal irgend sowas wenn du mit dem nfc-fähigen Telefon mit dem NFC
techrider da dran gehst dann sagt er irgendwie hier gibt's Informationen zu deinem Ball hier ist das kleine Kind was den in Bangladesch genäht hat oder so ne irgendwie
irgendwie solche weiterführende Informationen zu deinem bei.
Und jetzt wurde halt die die Theorie ersparen oder wurde ich gefragt von von Bloomberg BusinessWeek glaube ich ja.
Wie ist das denn hier mit dem NFC hacking weil da gibt's ja Vorträge wo Leute quasi schon Angriffe.
Er demonstriert haben die irgendwie über NFC funktionieren jetzt muss er zu sein diese diese Angriffe waren jetzt eher so ein bisschen soll ich mal von der,
von langen an den langen Haaren herbeigezogen and Natur nämlich wenn du da jetzt quasi einen Link reinmachen würdest,
der zu einer Applikation führt und diese Applikation ist bösartig und dein Opfer klickt dann irgendwie auf möchte ich hier aus und vertrauenswürdiger Quelle installieren,
auf meinem Android Telefon und ja ich gebe dieser App auch alle Rechte dann wäre es also theoretisch auch möglich gewesen über diesen Fußball mit einem manipulierten NSC tech,
irgendwie Donald Trump Handy zu infizieren wenn er einen Android nutzen würde und kein iOS,
aber dafür gab's jetzt quasi einen kleinen einen kleinen Lacher das nämlich,
das ist das also hier quasi ein ein Funkgerät ein Funken das Schiff in dem Fußball ist den Putin,
Bertrand geschickt hat der aber von dieser Chip hat von den Deutschen kam,
Anna das würde ich dann halt gefragt ob ich das für realistisch alte dass Donald Trump auf diese Weise gehackt wird und das war natürlich schwierig weil ich da mit der also beurteilen musste.
Würde Donald Trump mehrere Sicherheitswarnung ignorieren.
Und entgegen der Warnungen eine Schadsoftware aus russischer Quelle auf seinem telefon installieren.
Lässt sich schwer beantworten.
Und deswegen waren wir leider beim Blumen nicht ganz vollständig wiedergegeben das Zitat Mister Trump we have to ignore metal Security warnings,
intentionally Installer malicious software on this device since he is known for his outstanding consciousness and intelligence I can hardly imagine him falling foresteria Tech like this,
oh wait wurde aber nicht vollständig wiedergegeben.
Sie haben einfach nur gesagt cinetech wo it depends on the president falling for a silly attack like this.
Naja also ich halte das ja für äußerst unwahrscheinlich dass.
Putin irgendwie,
also das schöne ist ich habe den eigentlich gesagt hätte den Artikel könnt also nicht drucken das ist irgendwie einfach nur einfach nur albern ne aber andere Stelle ich so bevor Vivi Putin erwiderte,
wie hacken wir Donald Trump hacken wie in mit einem Ball.
Ich glaube deine Trump damit z.b. gar nicht so genug anfangen man merkt es schon als den entgegengenommen hat welche Schwierigkeiten er da irgendwie hatte,
das sind auf jeden Fall so die kleinen Lacher nebenbei.
Ja weil wir für die Kleinen Lara Irina ja ich fand es ganz ich falte die ich kann's halt erzählt jetzt ganz lustig aber ich bin jetzt erst das Ding irgendwie unter den unter seriös läuft war ich jetzt nicht von ausgegangen,
aber das ist wohl tatsächlich so gewesen dass die dass das Geschenk hat einer Prüfung unterzogen wurde und dabei ist eben dieses NFC-Tags aufgefallen,
citykoti wie so ein komisches.
Immerhin ANSYS gemerkt.
Haben Sie gemerkt ja.
Solinus an an dieser Stelle kommen wir zu unseren Terminen.
In Münchsteinach findet vom 9 bis 13 August III CMT Stadt die ich glaube dir das ist die,
Party mit den Worten habt ihr die schlechte Internetverbindung die selbstgemachten Pizzen Yoga beim Sonnenuntergang die liebevoll gemischten zu uns und die guten Gespräche an der Quelle aller Mathe vermisst zum neunten Mal veranstaltet der BZ.
Der Erlanger FRV discount Computerclub DIY CMP auf der Blümchenwiese.
Steigerwald bei Münchsteinach da ist tatsächlich die Quelle der Club-Mate und das Programm beginnt dann auch mit einer Besichtigung der Produktionsstätte.
Ihr könnt auch noch Einreichung bis zum 29 July machen Unterprogramm ed Sheeran.
Ja und wenige Tage später da könnt ihr dann gleich weiterfahren am kleinflecken Namen zu wernershöhe dass es in der Nähe von Hildesheim vom 16 bis 18 August 2000.
Woodstock 2018 stadtputztag ist so eine Art Camp für Podcaster aber nicht nur für solche die Podcast produzieren sondern.
Hörerinnen sind dort gern gesehen dass ein kleines überschaubares kennt man kann da bieten und gibt glaube ich auch noch ein paar,
Zimmer zu mieten kann man alles auf der Webseite herausfinden ja und wer will dahin dann wollen halt irgendwie alle hin die Podcasting Bereich irgendwas nach vorne bringen,
vor Ort sein wird dafür suchen mit verschiedenen Leuten mal über das Wochenende mal ein paar ganz dringende technische Sachen intensiver zu diskutieren ist bedeutet Workshops geben es gibt live Podcast.
Abgehalten werden etc.pp und wenn man sonst nicht weiß wie man sich einbringen soll kann auch einfach mithelfen und einfach dabei sein schönes Wochenende haben wie gesagt 16. bis 8. August.
Im Norden aber simone.
Und vom 23 bis 30 August findet in Berlin die next,
Grenzstadt in der Technischen Universität unter der Woche ist sohag Woche und am Wochenende geht's kinox.tox und Workshops also
25 und 26 gibt's dann dann auch so frontal Programm er unter anderem auch mit mir ich bin da verdonnert worden einen kleinen Vortrag zu halten,
und da kann man also ich ein bisschen mit nextcloud auseinandersetzen in der TU Berlin.
Ja damit wären wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen.
Jo habe ich nur irgendwas was ich sagen wollte es ist zu heiß es ist einfach nur zu heiß ich brauche das an.
Dass er geht so wirklich nicht mehr ich hab wirklich ihr Kreislauf.
Was Kreislauf nein Städte mal schön den Eimer Wasser unterm Tisch dazu sieht man jetzt auf Twitter als Ideallösung einfach die ganze Zeit die Füße im Wasser dann kommt man schon mal voran aber es ist in der Tat.
Heroin ich mir hier den Holzboden mit den nassen Füßen raus laufen.
Ja das ist jetzt genauso das Jahr mal und wie darauf hinzuweisen dass es mit dem Klimawandel jetzt auch echt ernst gemeint ist.
Ja ich habe aber eine schöne Lösung gefunden und zwar also was aufjedenfall unumgänglich ist ist jetzt mit der Sonne den Raum zu wechseln also da wo die Sonne nicht steht ist der Raum in dem ich sein möchte.
Und darf ich mich jetzt eher höher und schon eine sehr spät in meinem Leben mit Streaming-Server Servern auseinandergesetzt und streame jetzt also von meinem Plattenspieler.
Im im lokalen Netz die Schallplatten damit ich sie im anderen Raum dann mit dem Kopfhörer hören kann habe ich was habe ich was gemacht.
Doch auch mal ganz schön wenn man wenn wenn die Hitze erfinderisch macht das Problem ist die Server die jetzt für diese Streaming zuständig sind.
Stelle meine Sonne.
Baby ständig in der Sonne aber die sind im Winter eigentlich schon ganz angenehm für die Wärme und im Sommer Schwank ich jetzt so mit der Idee das vielleicht alles normal mit mit raspberry Pie es neu zu bauen oder so.
Heute erreichen gibt's bestimmt schon unten fertiges Projekt Wasser einfach mal heran sie.
Gibt es auf jeden Fall fertig ich habe das nämlich alles mit mit Docker gemacht ich mich endlich mal in diese Docker schwarze Joker Magie bewegt.
Und ich kann nur sagen das ist viel schwer zur Energie als man meint und funktioniert irgendwie so oft ganz ganz unheimliche Weise.
Also das ist echt das ist nicht gut.
Sag jetzt nichts falsches und sind die ganzen Kommentare nur voll mit dieser openforce Technologie Tesco.
Also ich mache die Sachen auf Wärme und diese konnte diese Container Sachen dieses Docker kam nachdem ich irgendwie 30 war und ist damit ganz eindeutig
wieder die natürliche Ordnung der Dinge und,
das darf man nicht machen.
Er hat mir für mich ist auch schon seit 20 Jahren alles so.
Ja danke sagen wolltest du noch.
Danke wie ich sag ja.
Und zwar das habe ich jetzt auch diejenigen die jetzt in danke vorkommen die werden die werden wissen warum ich gerade kurz von von meinem Docker Container und Streaming Setup erzählt habe das sind nämlich Chris ronny Nils,
hallo Anna,
Patrick und Florian denen sehr herzlich gedankt wird für kühle Getränke die ich hier zubereiten kann und einen Hörgenuss den ich jetzt in in der Wohnung hier habe und so weiter,
vielen vielen Dank euch dass er mich auch in der Hitze nicht zurück Last.
Ja und ich bedanke mich auch an alle die hier auch schon auf meine tausendundeins Daueraufträge Geschichte hin reagiert haben der tut sich in der Tat so einiges
so richtig im Blick wenn ich das erst im August haben aber der Trend sieht gut aus da sind jetzt glaube ich schon so Andy,
die 900er Schwelle ist auf jeden Fall schon genommen und sofern der ganz zuversichtlich dass ich hier meine magischen 5 % noch zusammen g****** bekomme.
Bild nicht weiß wovon ich rede der Zusendung euch das halt was er für dich gemacht und in der Freakshow ja.
Wetter noch einsteigen will das gerne mit der zu kommen bist wird dieser heißt sitze gerade ganz schön im Schatten von daher ich habe den habe ich auch gut reden ich bin hier glaube ich so oft paar 1000 m Höhe da wird dann auch noch ein nettes Lüftchen.
Pa 1000 Meter Höhe ja das wäre gut für mich also Berlin 33 Grad gerade.
Also unten im Tal ist richtig Senge sei schlimm ganz furchtbar bitte verhaften sie mich aber hier oben in den Bergen da hast du so permanenten Wind sucht das macht die Sache auch die ganz nice.
Eichenberg nee will ich nicht ich muss heute auch noch Fahrrad fahren ich will keine Berger so damit sind wir jetzt wirklich im belanglosen Teil der Sendungen angelangt und verabschieden uns.
Genau wie Dank fürs Zuhören wir bemühen uns auch weiterhin in der Urlaubszeit hier irgendwie den den Newsflow aufrechtzuerhalten bis dann tschüss.